si l'administration ne donne pas les
moyens de se protéger
gels hydroalcooliques et masque dans ce
cas là les policiers doivent exercer
leur droit d'alert droit de retrait et
pas de masque pas de contravention pas
de contrôle je m'appelle stein sa sgo
dont je suis le délégué général à la
communication pour le syndicat alliance
police nationale d'une grande majorité
d'unités non pas de masque n'ont pas de
gel hydroalcoolique donc c'est un peu
compliqué eu pour les policiers
d'exercer leur métier sereinement et
pire c'est que lorsque vous faites des
contrôles pendant 8 à 12 heures de
vacation et que vous contrôlez des
centaines de personnes vous imaginez un
peu les policiers deviennent des
propagateurs de virus quitte en plus à
ce qu'il le ramène à la maison qu ils le
propagent notamment dans les
commissariats et auprès de leurs
collègues
enfin c'est un non sens que de laisser
perdurer cette situation qui je le
rappelle est contraire à la guerre
sanitaires que nous livrons et quand on
sait que de plus en plus on a des
témoignages sur le terrain notamment
d'individus qui n'hésite pas à faire
exprès d'éternuer et de tousser même
pire comme je le disais de cracher vous
voyez l'importance qu'on soit dotée de
ce matériel et des exemples dans le 91
notamment chilly mazarin le premier
exemple du crachat c'était châteauroux
c'était il ya quelques jours les les
problèmes
je dirais sur la voie publique se
multiplient et du coup quand on dit que
les policiers sont en première ligne
ils le sont ils l'étaient avant sur la
violence maintenant ils le sont avec la
violence et en plus la propagation du
virus
je rappelle que nous avons dit 1131
collègues qui sont confinés et 257 qui
sont contaminés avec kobe de 19 déclaré
positif
nous on a dit stop si l'administration
ne donne pas les moyens de se protéger
gels hydroalcooliques et masque dans ce
cas là les policiers doivent exercer
leur droit dallaire droit de retrait et
pas de masque pas de contravention pas
de contrôle
donc lorsqu'on nous a retiré par exemple
comme avant-hier les masques ffp2 pour
les donner aux personnels de santé
nous avons toujours dit que
effectivement les masques de type ffp2
c'est très bien que les personnels de
santé en et lusage puisqu'ils n'ont plus
d'utilité que nous par contre on a dit
qu' il fallait que en remplacement on
nous donne des masques chirurgicaux et
là on ne comprend pas le ministre
l'intérieur a du mal à nous dire quel
est le stock a du mal à nous dire
combien de masques sont consommés par
jour et surtout quels sont les
directives très claires et pourquoi est
ce que dans certains endroits on nous
interdit de porter des masques ne pas
intervenir dans les quartiers trop chaud
je dirais que ça c'est c'est un vieil
adage qui qui qui perdure depuis des
années c'est que tout le monde
enfin surtout les autorités notamment
politiques ont mémoire les émeutes et ne
voudrait pas se retrouver avec une crise
majeure d'émeutes en plein milieu d'une
crise sanitaire des consignes écrites
pour ne pas intervenir dans les
quartiers nous n'en avons pas
connaissance maintenant il est clair que
on évite d'aller à l'affrontement
d'abord pour exposer inutilement les
policiers et ensuite pour éviter que
certains quartiers s'embrase plus que
plus que d'habitude parce que vous savez
rien de nouveau sous le soleil
la violence dans ces quartiers par une
minorité et je le redis parce qu'il faut
pas stigmatiser cette population qui
dans une grande
joe rites et respectent les règles du
confinement mais il y à une certaine
minorité toujours hostiles à la police
toujours hostile aux règles et aux lieux
à autorités de l'état qui n'hésitent pas
à braver tous les soirs notamment et
c'est bien pour ça que certaines villes
ont mis en place notamment des couvre
feux
[Musique]